[music] [music] design quantum technology from lower saxony where we
want to introduce you to activities that take place around the
quantum network and the quantum
ecosystem in the Hanover
Braunschweig region and that
depends above all on the
activities on the topic of quantum computers,
which I want to tell you about  would now like to give a first
introduction of what our
approaches are and how we hope
to be able to make significant progress in the next few years my name is christian
ospelt from i am from the institute for
quantum optics at the leibniz
university in hannover and from the ptb in brunswick
i wanted  starting the whole thing with a
brief definition of terms, namely
when it comes to computing,
all sorts of terms are always haunting the area
where you sometimes don’t know exactly
what you’re talking about and that’s why I
’ve sorted terms here on the lower right side of the slide that you
basically  classical
information processing in  sorting things out in a certain
sense on the right side, such
a supercomputer as you may
have seen in the media from
time to time, but then in
a certain sense this also includes terms of artificial
intelligence artificial neural networks
machine learning also actually
terms that have been
constantly in  have been in the media and
all of these different
approaches are ultimately based on
the binary coding of information
so that information can be
stored in zeros and ones and that
ultimately means the lamp is on or
the lamp is off and every operating state in
between, for example the
lamp  flickering is an undesirable
condition, among other things, this is also
clearly evident in the logo of our university,
which goes back to a signature of
leibnitz and where you can see the
coding of the binary number system sin
the decima in the logo then it
is so obvious that we  here
like this  have a diagonal dividing line
and then the area is arranged
at the top that man associates with
quantum information processing
and that is characterized precisely
by the fact that we are leaving this
paradigm here where we are only exactly
two operating states too long a
quantum computer is also based on a
two-level system for storage  of
information
but it is now not only allowed that
the system is in one of the two
states, i.e. light on light
off that is called its own state,
but also in any
superposition state of the two
states and it is favorable for these
superposition states on the
so-called  blog google visualize
here you can see here at the top right
that means basically everyone is good we
're in the wrong room for that we
're here in the boardroom then maybe we should have done it
better in the polar
bear but you can see that you can see
all the states  allowed those on this ball
are from the south pole of the
penguins there that fits again with
the birds to the north pole with the
polar bears and that is the state space
that can be occupied by a single quantum bit or cupid
very important for the nature of a
quantum computer is the superposition
principle that  and they are, so to speak,
the states on the equator that i
can not only find a system in one of
its two
states but also in any
superimposition of these two
states
and so one of the applications and for
quantum computers that caused a sensation at the very
beginning  and on which the
topic still hangs a lot, even though
it is actually not that directly
relevant, is cryptography,
namely based on a lot of the
encryption process which, as
we know it, is based on the fact that large numbers can be
very easily
multiplied by an even larger one  to
get number that it is very difficult but
one like that  Breaking down a large number into its
prime factors, to put it
bluntly, 15 has three times five to
fifteen is an easy task, but
15 equals three times five is a
difficult task if you do the whole thing
with large numbers and this
this and this into this this
imbalance in the  computing effort is
therefore
very important for classical computer science and in
1990 the likeable man here
peter shaw came along and found an algorithm
that allows you to run on
a quantum computer, whatever that
is, we will get to know one in a
reasonable amount of time
to break down large numbers into their prime factors and that was
basically an initial spark for this
field, after which many of the
well-known three-letter agencies that are
otherwise secretly on the move
began to be interested in this topic
,
fortunately this is not the
only application of quantum computers
but  the immediate application  ns
of quantum computers are more in the
area where quantum mechanics plays a role in the
microscopic behavior of
matter, for example
in chemistry chemistry is basically nothing
more than constantly observing the laws of
quantum mechanics then
material sciences pharmacy and
biology where you already  with
comparatively small cupid numbers
this application that we started with
can make a big difference cryptography
or breaking cryptography is
at the very end of the chain in terms of complexity and effort
how do you have
to imagine such a quantum algorithm
and that  the design of quantum
rhythms differs almost
fundamentally from how you how you
program in the classic way the
resources we have available it
doesn't get more mathematical andrew pitt
end the number of cubes and if you
then continue to calculate with the cubes if
you put the information into the cube  it  s
processed then you do that in the
so-called hilbert space that is nothing
other than the space of states that is available to
the system i.e.
all the information you can store in it
and this hilbert space has
the highest two to the power n that’s
a bit  become
more mathematical but we have all gotten to know what exponential growth means
in the last year and a half
so that
simply means if you start with a
comparatively small number
of atoms from kibiz
then you actually have an exponential
a huge state space available
and do it now  let's see the small
generations test someone here knows
no but
if i switch on maybe
that's michael schanze like that appeared
here now that's also why that
's one of the best-known series and
german children's television has been running since the
70s i've also looked in the  80s
and in the end the kids always have to
au  jump f one of these fields
and then it says 1 2 or 3 if you are
really correct you can see when the
light goes on that means for us it is
the quantum mechanical mesz process like
cancer at the end of the light when we
want to see what condition our
lapwings are in  and then you have
to decide between two states
for the polar bears or for
the penguins, i.e. for one room
or for the other room and
accordingly the north pole or the
south pole of this block sphere, that means
the measuring process basically does all of that
what happened in the meantime
broke again and that's why it's so important
that you think quantum algorithms from the end from the
end from the end of the
measurement thinks here and in between
it's always
well forbidden to look if you
switch on the light in between
then the whole calculation is broken the  measuring
process makes the train projects the
state destroys it reduces the amount
in unite information  Names that you have
saved in a drastic
way, of course you have to ask
yourself now your neighbor comes along and says I
have a small startup and I have built
quantum computers will not
buy them then the question naturally arises now
do you want to buy it and that
’s definitely the case  at the moment also a politically
relevant question and that's why you
have to ask yourself how are
quantum computers actually evaluated what makes a
machine good with a classic
computer there isn't one
value is not just the clock frequency
or the number of memories the number of
processors but ultimately you have to
look at the whole package and it's
very important the cue paid is
often the focus of public
attention but there are also
other criteria such as
computing time or competition time the
ratio the error rate and the
connectivity i.e. which cupid can
actually interact with which cupid
for classic co  mputer
is and it goes without saying that
every picture can actually change with every other
picture what we
can also pull every bit out of the hard drive
and insert it into the processor can then do arithmetic operations with
any other picture
can push the whole thing back and then
back in  take something else that is not a
matter of
course and one of the criteria
i think is very important and that is the
error rate i have shown such a cd
and what that means he
i wanted to briefly
illustrate how the cd is as the
cd is there  because
[music]
that maybe someone else knows from the
90s 1000 i still have a few cds at
home and because such a cd is
usually
indestructible we come from lower saxony and lower saxony there are several ways to
break such a cd
you can
walk over it with rubber boots or drive over it
with a tractor or with
a local electric car  n manufacturer and
usually the thing
still plays afterwards and of course it does
because the redundant information is
stored on it because the information
is stored several times a cd
does error correction or Fellmann
the cd player makes error correction in the
quantum computer can do that too  this
is then called quantum error correction,
however, quantum
error correction is a very complex
process and it works
really well if the
individual calculation step has an error of
less than 0.01 percent. that is the
first question you ask your rights
from your neighbors with the quantum
computer startup  should actually ask is
what is your error rate and you
should only tick it if it
is below 0.01 percent or ten to the
minus 4
speaking a little more mathematically now there are two leading
approaches to implementing quantum computers experimentally
one is he
we  track and that  are the
stored ions that the ratio
of coherence time to computing time what
i already mentioned is
excellent the error rate is less than
0.1 percent so we are still about
an order of magnitude if it's even my turn at
this point where you can use quantum
error correction in a scalable
can be used wisely and where you can
then make the systems really big
and pull them into many cubes
remember I said
just having individual bits
doesn’t do anything in the classic way either, but you can
only do something with them
when they also interact with each other when you work with
them
the other architecture that i
don’t want to go into now is the
superconductor architecture that can calculate. these are such
small switching elements that are also implemented in the
microstructures.
coherence in the 100
microsecond range counts very fast computing times in the
range of 40 to 100 nanoseconds and
an error rate that typically  one
size  order is higher how does it work
now with the jews fall how
store like lapwing in individual
atoms we start with such a
structure here that looks like
gold bars that are placed next to each other
these are actually
microscopic gold
bars that are separated from each other by a vacuum vacuum  there
is a chip on the surface of each of
these gold bars, which are micrometers in size
, you can apply individual voltages
and, for example, you can put these
middle electrodes, so we call the
gold bars, on an alternating voltage
that is not 50 50 hertz and
from the socket, but more like that in the
radio range 100 megahertz that's
why it's also just called a
radio frequency and above the
surface a potential tube is created on this
dashed line
where you can store ions
so they don't want to leave
once they sit on this line the
ones from the electric ones  fields
locked up and we  If you now also apply
a positive voltage to these outer electrons the
electrons we are
dealing with the charged atoms in which we
store the information the cubis they
are also in a soda bottle like
magnesium or calcium, for example,
that's a good reward  for such
a quantum computer they are also found
in a soda bottle and they
are usually positively charged
, i.e. they can be enclosed by positive
voltages if we now
set the inner electrodes to a
negative voltage then you can,
for example, have two individual millions
trap two atoms above the
surface and it looks like this, for
example,
this is what a picture of these atoms looks like from up here on the
left side and this picture is
obtained by shining a laser beam on the
atoms, then they are
excited and always  if you
fall back into the ground
if you fall off  rain then they emit
light and
this can be imaged on a camera with a microscope. laser systems are usually used for
this, such as what i have
shown you here in the picture.
these laser systems have the disadvantage
that they are usually very complex and
[ __ ]  are and these
laser systems are usually used in the jews
fall quantum
computer which your neighbor probably
wants to sell you also to control the
cube it's so
to
convert you radiate laser pulses to do these arithmetic operations and that is
comparatively complex and fills
several optical tables  in his lab
and busy bunch doctor been
putting this together for
quite a while we take a different approach to
controlling the lapwings
and that is we send
ac currents through some of these gold bars through
send
little reminder you are
dealing with ac voltages now to the
ac  stream flows so an s  electricity
and it flows with my
microwave frequency and stimulates the
atoms so that you can
carry out arithmetic operations these currents
are in the surface, which means
you no longer need complex
laser systems that are distributed over several rooms
of this size, but
really only one  small pin through
which the control signal flows into the chip
rhein is an approach in which
the entire control is integrated for this
you need microstructures like
you can see on this slide
it's a
scanning electron microscopy image in
the middle where you look like this from above  a
chip looks on it and the jews are then stored above it
in a vacuum
and we want to show you how that works
with a small virtual laboratory
tour where you can take them to the
laboratory and i'll hand over
control over there to the director
hello my name is it will be cooler
and there will be more customers mr great glad
that you  to be able to welcome you today to the virtual laboratory
tour in the quantum computer laboratory
first of all i would like to introduce you to the
team that the laboratory
admits today i have been a
scientist at
the Physikalisch-Technische Bundesanstalt for three years now and I manage the quantum computing laboratory behind
the camera here tim copies himself  also
incidentally project manager of the quantum
valley lower saxony is of
course i can not run this laboratory
alone but i also have
active support from my
colleagues
right at the experimenting control pc
sits markus stuber hello and left at
the camera control instrument driver
first of all i would like to explain the conceptual
difference between computers  and
quantum computers
the fundamental building blocks of a
classic computer are transistors
in normal computers such
as cell phones, billions of transistors are built in
nowadays a
transistor has two inputs and one
output  ang the inputs and outputs are voltages
so-called binary signal if
a voltage
is present a logical 1 is represented, otherwise a
logical 0 this represents a
classic bit that can be either 1 or
0 is due to free some
transistor its exciting so there is
also voltage at the output  not in all
other cases if
there is no voltage at just one of the inputs,
there is also
voltage at the output that is why you cannot forcibly shoot back from the
output signal to the
input signals the
transistor destroys information as under
certain conditions
the logic in the quantum world
works fundamentally  different in the
sick logic no information is
destroyed
that's why we can carry out completely new types
of calculations during
this laboratory tour i would like to show you by
means of experiments with
stored
ions how we realize this edge
logic and that this always whom  n
we keep them until we lose the
information,
so we usually have them in
a vacuum chamber like this because these are also
quantum systems that are highly
sensitive and
must be isolated as best as possible from their surroundings,
such as from the air in the room, for example, if I now have the air
particles on our ears
push that destroyed and to the computer
to show what's going on inside such
a maintenance chamber as it
is now we have a
close up of such an ion trap over here
what we see here is
a circuit board that has various connectors
connectors for microwaves
and connectors  for
control signals here in the middle
we see the chip where the ions are actually
trapped surrounded by
a pfarrer day cage in copper colors because the ions are
charged we have to isolate them as best as possible from all fields that we do
n't apply externally
for this this
copper-colored driver is the cage with  a
grid on top and around all sorts of
tax signs  to be able to create ale and arithmetic signals
, we need microwave
connections and connections for potentials
connections for voltages
the
other conductor tracks that you can see here on
this circuit board filter the signals as
best as possible to enable clean and
reliable operation of the
quantum computer
what we are seeing now is a part  of our
laser system at the very back of the
table and is then progressively converted towards the front on this
table
from
infrared wavelengths that you cannot
see to the bright red that you
see here,
finally to
ultraviolet radiation, and the whole thing
then ends here on this table
in a one structure  of many
different
mirrors and glass fibers and lenses
polarizing optics all of which
are used to
split the beam to control
in direction and in its
spatial form and then to
send it out and then to
control and manipulate
it  e stralis ultraviolet that means
you can't see anything but
ultraviolet radiation can
usually be seen with softeners in paper
that then fluoresces
normally it is the laser radiation so
that we always have protective goggles in the
laboratory today we want to show that but that's
why we have now made the laser radiation
correspondingly weak  and
can you sir sign that it is
actually on the table ingo
can you please show it and
here we see one of our
laser beams as it is propagated along the table
and manipulated
so to speak and is also split up into different laser beams to make it
suitable  our manipulating it, as
you have just seen from the readers, there
are a large number of optical
elements
necessary to operate such lasers,
which then all have to be
adjusted individually by hand and
really built up in sometimes years of work
and each individual component
here pl  it has to be etched on the
optical table it's much
easier if you don't manipulate it with
laser beams but if you
manipulate it with
microwaves
microwaves can also
be used to manipulate your structure
accordingly and
it really looks like this and doesn't have to be
here  place all the components individually on the
optical table, but you
can really buy the components and
you really just have to plug the cables
together and you have
amplifiers here, you have
switches on the radio africa here, so turn this
microwave on and off you have so
-called splitters, which are basically parts of the
signal  is branched off so that you have a
diagnosis with which you can later
check whether the microwave is
running exactly as it should and in the end you
can actually send the whole thing to our chamber to our chip via a single
cable that then goes out here
we
then microwave our ions with these
being able to control manipulate
now i also want to present my background a little bit
here
what kind of instruments are that are also like that here in the
background
up here we see an instrument that
monitors whether the wavelength of our
readers is correct
that here are instruments that
control that
ours  readers are also on the right
wavelength these oscilloscopes
allow and read optical
intensities
here we have controllers for
lasers that deliver current and voltage
,
so to speak, here we
have generators that generate the sine waves for
our microwave and
down here we have electronics that also look at
our microwaves  are really
stabilized on each other so we
have now reached the point where
we want to take a look at yours as well
and how we want to see
how your trap is supposed to come we
have this structure here which contains a
lot of elements we
also somehow control m  must
this structure is controlled by
this experiment control computer
which we will then activate immediately,
which is controlled by markus vergleich
but first we want to look at
how we see the boys at all we see the boys
with a camera that
is under the table here and this
camera is looking  from below upwards via
a mirror or an imaging system
onto the ion there it is hanging upside
down and then you look at it from below and
cdu the whole dazzle we
then send it to this computer so
we now show it again in large format on the
screen
right now this camera is still black on one camera
but we'll
see one of yours in a moment
what we're going to do now or what might it be doing right
now it's going
to be markus in your
store markus out loud here please
and that we can now see on this
screen  is that we
loaded a few, so a chain of ion
about three boys who have now appeared on the camera
d  as means we have
now successfully
in our region case in our
packaging you can load
how load and we catch so here you can
see a virtual close-up of our
ion traps in the middle of the picture at the top
right of the ion trap we have a
piece of the value metal from which we  want to
vaporize atoms for this we
first used a laser pulse
to heat up the metal for a short time
now atoms are directed towards the
ion trap from wins and these atoms
are then transformed into leon with the help of a second
laser this is done
by shooting one of the electrons out of the
nuclear waste this happens
exactly  then if the atoms also
fly over this ion trap now we can keep
them on board and with the help of our you accident on board
and place a third laser is
finally needed to
make our region shine or
fluoresce now we have
one of yours loaded in our case we
have  so
booted up our sick computer there  s glow shows and
later in what state yours
is
the so-called atomic level structure
shown here on the right that brilliance all the
main that the committee to determine in a
variety of states
by means of precise
adjustment of our laser radiation the laser frequency and
who exactly one of the states for
shining then we look for
exactly one shining and one non-
shining state
this creates a cupid the other
states can then be ignored
we have just loaded one of your
customers with our accounts computer
and now we want to see how
we can manipulate it in its state
can you will it be able to transfer your from the bright
state of the logical 1 to the
dark state of the logical 0
neither is our experiment control
our computer mark can you
please start the experiment
thank you
very much without looking at it more closely
if we now  here  r on my left
again in the detailed recording of
this experiment in this
experiment we would see here
with your states that it is first light and
then it is
dark after a while and then it
also becomes light again
what happened here is that we use
microwave radiation  in order
to manipulate this state of the kibiz
from light to dark
back to light that it is a
reversible
union operation as just mentioned earlier
all these operations are
reversible reversal was
here we have a perfect state
and here we have a perfectly dark
state in
between shines  it seems like it got into a
state that has
steadily gotten a bit
darker now, as if it has
its not only the light and the
dark but also levels in
between
and as if it's just becoming more than one
state like what we just saw in the
experiment  I would
now like to try again using
clear examples bi
to explain this better i
always like to imagine a coin
and the coin also has two possible
states who don't
let it fall to the ground i can either
have heads or i can have tails if i
now have the coin with numbers pointing upwards
let it fall then the number will
always come out i can
now say the coin is in its 1
state in the glowing state if i
now take the coin and turn it over
then it will always end up in the head
state or in the 0 state
but now i can  also turn the coin on
its side because we didn't
drop the coin on the side
ours and it can either
fall heads it can fall tails and if i
repeat that a lot of times now
i would have was it in the middle
i would have half  one and half 0
half bright
and half dark
the same we are also doing an
experiment with our ions we can take
the young w  we can prepare them originally in
a dark or in a light
state and
then rotate them slowly, then here they
are half neck half dark and then
slowly rotate them further and here
the ions are 100 dark and we
just saw that in our experiment
these  In principle, coins have the same degrees of
freedom, the same
possibility to manipulate them as our
cubes, which is why they are also called single
cupid
rotations operations, where I can rotate a
single cuban
, of course,
these mutations are
not made with our
hands, but somehow the ion trap must do it
too  happen and that
happens on our ion trap
via conductive paths and the conductive paths
on which give the so-called microwaves, i.e. currents that oscillate
very quickly
and these rapidly
oscillating currents allow us to transfer the
state of the kibiz from 1
to 0 in a controlled manner these are the
individual operations  the single
quantum bit gates
we have just seen the one qubit
operations now there are
still important ingredients for the
quantum computer, the so-called two
qubit operations this is also the logic
in our computers i want to
try to introduce and
explain that
two quantum bit gates or
entanglement operations are also
operations that correlate our two qubits
with each other what is called
correlation this can also
be imagined using a somewhat simpler example
correlation means that,
for example
, I am
on my way to work in the morning and I am on my way to work
when it is good  there are a lot of green
traffic lights running and if i drive over the green traffic
light then i know that the
local administration has done it
well and that the back side to me has a
red traffic light, but i
don't have to look at the traffic light on the back side,
it's enough that i do  on my
green traffic light cocker and then i know  ch
immediately that the other traffic light has to be
red that's classic correlation
relation means that I have two systems
from which I can infer the state of one
system from the state of the other
system
these are also with us is the equivalent
of the two qubit gates  where you
also prepare a state where
I can deduce the state of one of us from the state
of the other you us
we have now arrived at the two
qubit gates
the heart of
the operation for a quantum computer
we can now do another
experiment here where we then  right on
my left side I want to
show the experimental control computer
again I had to be really
nice and
what we are doing here now and
what we have to look at now that we have
two years in our region
and these two
are either kept so that they are
dark or  one of them is and the
other is probabilities the
blue curve is either  both union
that help in regions the red curve
is that in regions are dark and the
green curve is exactly one of the
two ions bright while the other is
dark after about a
millisecond you reach
a state that expresses the found logic
by quasi
optionally has a bright state or
had a state in which the two
hessians or had a state in which
both are dark but not a
state in which one of the two young is
bright and the other is dark
this logic expresses the
entanglement that we see in this at this point
of the  experiments have also achieved
namely garden entanglement between
the two particles
after
additional time we found this
operation to run we have
approximately reached the original initial state again that means we
have already gone back to the young bright
after both johns stops
in the work in which  we create an
entangled state here h  aben and
have also created an entangled state
here, just realized the franconian logic
gates,
so with that our laboratory
tour comes to an end, you will be
shown today that you can successfully operate a 2
judith quantum computer,
the challenges that are now
facing this branch of judith quantum computers
as well  to expand to several
cupids valley lower saxony it is
now a matter of already demonstrated
technologies such as transport
union storing ions and the 1
and 2 will operation
merge everything into a single
common platform in order to produce a 50
cupid franc computer with
it  I would like to
thank you very much for your attention
and say goodbye goodbye
yes after this brief insight into the laboratory
where we got to know the elementary arithmetic operations of
a quantum computer
so the individual shows jupiter
lukather there is also a
kl  assic computer we now want to look
at how you can make the whole thing bigger
so you can go over to several cubes
and here you can see the
picture of our ion trap again with
the voltages that we apply to the electrodes in
order to close the atoms above the
surface  save it
and we can use yes domes are
positively charged we can now take a
look at what happens if you charge the
electrodes on the right side a
bit more positively and the red
electrons on the left side do
something in the voltage and then
the atoms migrate  of course to the right
to the left because they are repelled by the positive
voltages on the right side
and are sucked in by the
slightly lower positive voltages
on the left side
so basically a mini
particle accelerator cern at the
micron level
shouldn’t be anything new in that respect
with electric fields i.e.
particles charged particles also i  n the
area how can you
use this now to build a
quantum computer with many atoms with many clubs
and for that
i want to show you a short
movie what you can see here on this
animation is the surface of
such a jew fall quantum computer
with  many cubes there are
no cubes in there at the moment but what
you can see are two
bright rails in the middle that go through such an
intersection such solid
lines and these lines are again the ones that
lie on the alternating voltage, i.e.
along this structure the like this
lying cross-shaped on the surface
you can store cubes everywhere and
next to them are these segmented these
small tiles you can apply voltage to these electrodes in
order to then transport the
particles back
and forth above the surface and that is exactly what
we want to do now we have in
the rear area towards the horizon,
so to speak, the area  h where we load the tubes
into the trap and that's exactly what's
happening now, the laser beams are used to
load an ion 2 johnen for three
years and then transport them out of the
loading register as
you
would like to fill a kibitz into the quantum computer in
the local  memory and then you
start to calculate to do this you transport
one ion into the calculation zone and
then transport a second one into the
same calculation register apply
this microwave pulse and
calculate which then
transports another pair out again transports another pair in
that just that  is the
rule of the quantum algorithm which pairs you have to
push in now does
another arithmetic operation has two
qubits in the arithmetic zone does
another arithmetic operation and as I said the
rule in which
order this has to happen and how long it
is the quanta  algorithm and at the end
michael schanze comes then the
light comes on  switched an
11 the measuring process a 1
a
01.11.10 another 1 again a zero and
another zero and that is the result
of the quantum calculation that is the end
of the quantum algorithm if you want to
make such a quantum computer big
then you have to  implement this transport
mechanism
now i wanted to give you a quick
summary of what we've
learned so far we've seen how
millions can catch up on the
right side by applying electric
fields to a microchip we
've seen we
trap the boys with lasers  invite you to be able
to detect and we have
seen that there are processes for which
you definitely need the laser and
we have learned that we can carry out the arithmetic operations with
microwaves that we couple into this
chip and that is a highly
integrated technology that from  great
advantage is because the rake mechanism,
so to speak, with d  a chip grows it is
built directly into the chip it is not a
large, complex laser system
that sits around it and that is the this
mechanism that we have demonstrated
there is practically the first
highly integrated quantum gate with
stored jews for quantum computers
we have because of these microwaves
signals from microwave technology is just
very well established the seats here
with my wireless microphones in
my in my phone so have
extremely low error rates and are
already an order of magnitude better
than that google processor that
made a splash two years ago or that
's a  characteristic that is
also inherent in the jewish platform in a certain sense.
we have now joined forces within
the framework of the cofresco, a project with generous support from the lower saxony
ministry for
economics, science and culture and
the volkswagen foundation to develop
a corresponding over the next five years
to build a machine that works with at least 50
jukic and above all
i told him how rated
could computers have direct interaction
between each cupid that you have in
this processor and calculate at least one
or two orders of magnitude better
than what is currently available anywhere
is available in the world
and in addition very different
expertise comes together there is the
expertise in nanophotonics and
computer science from the Technical
University of Braunschweig plus the
expertise of the ptb in the jews fall
technology and the expertise and
quantum optics and theory and application of
a Leibniz University in Hanover that
so it's a place to be if you want to be there this
is where the people you
need to implement something like this come together
and we want to we're really a
full stack consortium that means we
can map every aspect of this this
technology you look
down here so up there  the picture that we it
the ko  llegen in the ptb has even
managed to squeeze a similar apparatus
in the context of optical clocks into a structure
of two rigs
and
make it transportable, so to speak, and of
course we also want to rely on this expertise for the quantum computers
that have the same
basic technology obligations  then work by
profession and my colleague beach is now telling you exactly where optical
clocks are concerned and how you can still
use them the quantum technology
is basically more than the quantum computer
[applause]
for the nice transition and also a
guide
i think we need  now the
other set of slides the next
exactly
in the following i would like to
show you, as already announced by mr osberghaus, what else you can do with
quantum technology and in
particular go into the application in the
field of optical clocks
i have
brought you a number here that shows the number  maybe
relatively coincidentally  ig out
probably
none of you know this number this is the very
special number
that the first peculiarity in this
number is for those who are familiar with
scientific notation is that it has
18 significant digits and this
number is the best measured 8 o'clock
constant the  mankind has ever
measured and it is essential that the
frequency ratio of two optical
clocks optical clocks are the most precise
measuring instruments that we
currently have available and currently we
do not see any limitations to
actually being
able to realize more than 18 digits in our measurements
how is that  principle of clocks in general
we need something that oscillates,
for example a
pendulum clock or a swimming pool rotating first and then
we count these oscillations
either with a sundial or with
a mechanical counter or simply
electronically
and a clock would be implemented if
we counted all cycles without even
one  losing a single cycle of it
and you can already see the
evolution here the trend is towards
higher and higher frequencies the rotation of the earth the earth
oscillates once a day rotates once
around its own axis the pendulum clock
strikes once a second is
finally back and forth and because such a
oscillator we have many thousands of
oscillations per second
and this trend can actually
continue the faster the oscillation the
better the watch will be in the end
now if i have such a watch now i
ask myself i am of course looking forward to it
just like with the quantum computer
why what is it then anja if
we want to sell my neighbor with the startup
watch yes what do i have to pay attention
to in the specifications
in what he tells me what the watch can
do what is the talk what are the
relevant sizes and what watches are there  there are
exactly two relevant variables that
we call exactly i hold and stability and
you can do that very nicely il  lusting
after another file soldier
target where i constantly
try to hit the center with darts
i can either
always throw past the center with a relatively large scatter
or I can throw past the center
but with a smaller
scatter or I aim with a large one
scatter right in the center and what i
want to have in the end
is that i
always hit the center with very little
scatter and affect in the broadcast means
accuracy for us and the scatter
means stability so the more stable i can
cast, the more confident i am in the cast
the more stable I am then the result is
exactly what we have with the watch as
well the watch has
to do this the oscillation has to correspond as closely as possible to
a fundamental
oscillation without any
additional shifts and it has to
always oscillate exactly the same, i.e. repeatably the
same, and of course that’s obviously the case
the pendulum clock and also a
quartz oscil  lator these are mechanically
manufactured elements, each one is different
and they are also sensitive to external
disturbances, of course, such as temperature,
humidity and so on and
it was found out some time
ago that in the eighteenth
century people came up with
it when they were the first  atoms have
discovered the car with hard line
as in each atom of a species is
identical to the other atom and atoms
have discrete transitions in
mr. excursion from casting the cubes or the
cube was realized through such a
transition we call it a transition
in the optical
that worked so well
right away here you can see pictures of cesium from
tours that are operated here and there at the ptb in
braunschweig the ptbs are also a member of
the cotton valley lower saxony and these
are among the most accurate cesium
tubes in the world and we see  here
in the picture we see a cloud of
cesium atoms symbolizing what then
the two states also have and the
second that we have today is
defined on exactly this transition
frequency and it doesn't just end with
a heart or with a few tens of kilos
, but it oscillates at 9
gigahertz, i.e. nine billion times per
second
and here  in the photo you can see where these
clocks are here in the background to the
right of the middle you can see the
cesium fountain clocks that are here
and actually make the german time
the people's time is distributed
via a transmitter in
mainflingen the dcf 77 receiver when
you have a radio clock or something like that then it
receives the signal from this transmitter that
reaches over 2000 kilometers and is used
for a lot of applications not only
privately but also for
applications in society as a whole
so now the question is now so that
the end of the road has already been reached
that  we can use this
illustration to see how the
different clocks work  n ranging from
chinese water clocks to oscillating
ears
up to quartz crystal clocks and cesium
from tours the question is can
this steep increase in
uncertainty or
descend and security so what is
stated here is essentially
how many fractions of a second the clock
would go wrong  in one day and
there we are from thousands of seconds per
day we are now going to 100 picoseconds
so that is 10 - 12 seconds
for one cycle in one day the question
is can this be continued and the
answer is yes
optical atomic clocks
themselves set the trend  continued, among
other things, because they have a higher
frequency from situations we are
then actually your very bizarre
situation up to date because we already have watches of
this quality class running
and
we can no longer specify their crossover frequency in hearts
because we use the heart unit on the
the se second based can no longer
be realized precisely enough because  which is realized on the
basis of cesium by
seniors and they are simply no longer
accurate enough, so we can only
measure frequency ratios between optical clocks in order to then
get an accuracy of 18 digits, so why do
we want optical clocks to have the higher
frequency, I already had that  mentioned, the
higher the oscillation period or the oscillation frequency,
the
more precisely I can of course also
measure the time. You can see that relatively
well here if I were to measure 0 here
, then I have a
smaller subdivision if I hear
frequencies, it is also the case if
if you have a meter ruler that only has meter
markings then it will be
difficult for you to have millimeters if
you have a millimeter scale then
millimeters are easy and that's exactly how it is
here too then we want to have narrow
transitions these are very similar
transitions to the ones you were able to use for
computing  are used so that this is the
size here that I specified
So I just divided the width by the
crossover frequency is the relevant
variable in this
context
, then we also want to ensure that we always hit the center of the dartboard exactly, we want the
shifts in our frequency, which we
then measure, to be as small as possible
and that's why we want  that the
atoms we use here are as insensitive as possible
to external
interference such as electromagnetic
fields, for example, that is the third
criterion we have and the idea
here is that although the magnitude of the
shift is approximately the same for
cesium fountains and optical clocks,
because the  but the frequency is higher
, it is less important,
so we also gain here with the
optical clocks,
right here are a few more
control effects, now I come to the
principle, how does such an optical one work
, we
start with a laser
that oscillates  usually at  500
terahertz that's a very fast
oscillation that's 5 times 10 to the power of 14
oscillations and in the second it should be
such a laser and these are exactly the
periods that we want to count in the end
for the optical clock so laser
and its frequency in particular  can of
course drift over time that
means we have to stabilize the frequency
to an optical
transition in atoms like that is
symbolized here is so our
reference is transition in such a one in
its atom and we are therefore asking
exactly how we explained
it to you  here we have the ground state who
the excited clock transition which we
either get excited or not
and whether that is the case or not shows
us when we emit this yellow light
, the atom remains either help
when it is in the other
state or it becomes dark  if
we stimulated it to the upper state and
from a large number of such experiments
we can say that we will and will fail  he derives
signals from which we know how we
have to change the laser frequency so that the
laser radiation corresponds exactly to this
transition. that's basically how
it's done and then always
stabilized on it. in the end, of course, we also want to do
something with the
light and there's a device for that  what
you can now
buy commercially is a
so-called frequency comb that divides
the optical frequency for us incredibly
fast is faster than any
electronics that we have available
divides this frequency down into the radio
frequency range where we
can count it electronically again and where we can
also count them  can then compare the clock with other ears
well the analogy i like to use here
is tuning a musical instrument our laser is the
violin here and our atom is the
frequency reference as
shown here and then you also change
the voltage in the side side around  tune the
frequency exactly to the reference
and gen
that's basically how it works with optical clocks
,
here in the cotton valley lower
saxony we are in the fortunate position
that we can set a few records worldwide
we have the
most stable clock lasers in the world we have
the first transportable optical clock
we have built watches that we have the
best watch in europe which are also
among the best in
the world from an international point of view and we operate the
longest phase route in europe or in
the whole world actually the
fiber route itself is of course in
europe at watches
to be able to compare with each other and these are all activities
that will be carried
out with and in mainly by the ptb within the framework
of the
kvl it just like you without an optical atomic clock
from you have already seen a similar picture
with Mr. outlook on
that is also one of those  the optical table that
follows is with optics the atoms
are very small here in the middle and
will  n trapped in the trap as you
see here as you see here they are
still relatively microscopic
macroscopic traps then the goal
is to miniaturize these traps and then also be
able to capture multiple ions
so we can make the clock even
better about it now there is one  the
main questions that may
also interest you is who
needs 18 asks here actively berlin's
s- and u-bahn are still too late
me myself too
who needs something like that at all there is
actually a whole range of
applications that can benefit from such highly
precise measuring instruments that
one is we can test fundamental
physics i would like
to give you an example right away
and navigation is of course based
on highly accurate clocks
that move in satellites the better the clocks there
are, the more precisely the
satellite navigation that you use on your
cell phone every day works  presumably we
can use large networks sy  chronize
and we can make heights better and
that is also a perhaps
unusual example was also what
i would like to
go into very briefly i will come to the fundamental
tests we have a relatively well-
functioning model of our
physical world view, i.e. the
standard model of particle physics
but there is  actually a lot of
unanswered questions, for example we know
from cosmological investigations that
there must be something like dark energy and dark matter and we have no
idea what that is supposed to be we
just don't know and the idea now is
that we can use highly precise clocks
that over  could compare the time
and then see if the clocks are
starting to diverge, if
the clocks will oscillate towards the ante, if there are
steps in the frequency
ratio and if there are such
steps or such oscillations then it
could indicate that the
clocks are getting darker  matter interact
the  could lead to such oscillations and to the
divergence of
clocks now in the way we can
look is there maybe something like
dark matter or we can exclude models
of dark matter by comparing
such clocks actually
well i can reassure you currently
nothing has been found  yes
so
currently no changes in
natural constants or an interaction
with dark matter have been discovered with these clocks,
but we are building the clocks
better and better in order to be able to
limit them accordingly. the second
application that i would like to show you
is perhaps a bit more
bizarre  in fact one of the
main applications due to which optical
clocks are now being further developed
and that is relativistic
geodesy which is based on an
effect predicted by einstein
namely the gravitational redshift
einstein predicted as part of his theory of
relativity
t that clocks that stand on the
floor run slower than clocks
that stand on the table and on the
ground is the difference in rate that we
call 10 - 16 so that the relative
frequency differences or
difference in rate of the two clocks on the
floor and on the  Standing on the
table means that if we have two watches
that are far apart and
we know that if they
are standing next to each other at the same height
and we then make a
frequency measurement over the large
distance, then we can use
the measured frequency to make differences
both clocks exactly the height difference
extra here
and that is exactly this new era, this
relativistic geodesy where we
want to have transportable clocks, for
example a clock at the amsterdam
bowling race a clock at the ptb via
the fiber optic connection that i
showed and then actually
a direct one  connection of the cave system
in germany at least one point of the
pt  b get as far as the height is concerned, this
could resolve a great many discrepancies that
currently still exist in the height models of
the countries, we
can look at climatically relevant data,
i.e. the height of the postal jar, exhaust air from the northern hemisphere, whether
other countries are sinking,
sea level rise, these are all
things  which we could address with
such transportable optical books
well we need transportable
optical clocks and bought them out
has already been mentioned the first
result in this context was
exactly how to ship a complex
optical structure into a rack
with certain target specifications
i don't want to go into detail
about that it runs away from the normal socket
can be carried around relatively
easily it's ten times better than
anything commercially available is based
on a single trapped ion is
equipped with relatively
standard technology
and  we can also off we have
an upgrade path to actually make the watch one of the
most accurate watches in the world the watch
is currently running and the
sale has already indicated the
same technology we
developed for this came to the quantum was
used to build the quantum computer  Good
ones are coming and the technology that is now being further developed in the quantum computer, including chip technology,
which is then also used here in
optical clocks.
Well, that's the end of it. I hope I was
able to show you that optical
clocks are currently the most accurate measuring instruments in the world
there is still no limit
to making the clocks
better and that there is a whole range of
applications that are also very practical in
nature thank you very much
[applause]
thank you very much for being there
we are now hoping that we will be
fascinated by catching individual
atoms could wake
you up a bit we could give you hay  te
i think show that mr schmidt just did
in his lecture that with
the laser beams you have an extremely precise
oscillator available and that
you can measure frequencies of laser beams very
well with individual ions and
thus build optical clocks that
there is a lot of technological  overlapping also
gives quantum computers that the readers
are not so good if you want to stabilize their
envelopes as precisely as possible
their their their
performance, so to speak, the amount of
light that is in there that we do this for the
purpose of quantum computers with these
integrated microwave
components that are in  the chips are inside and
that's a lot of back and forth
between these two
research directions, which is why it
makes sense to be pursued in the same place and by
the same people
and that in both cases
precision is important - in the case of optical
watches, precision  that of the
vibration that is measured on it and
i  m the case of the quantum computer on the
precision of the gods pulses that are used
to do the arithmetic operations
so that you can then calculate with many kubitz
at some point because a
single arithmetic operation is precise enough for you
and you can therefore afford to line up
many of them together
we left you a lot  time for
questions that's why the coach also has the
microphone and if you
want to ask a question about it then
you're welcome to do so since people are
connected to us
I would ask you to wait a moment until
you have the microphone in
your hand with it  the fact that those who are
connected to the stream can then also see
can hear
thanks first of all many lectures is was
very exciting thank you and my question
relates to the laboratory tour because it was
said that the committee used atoms
and today I ask why the decision was made about
relays  has and what
considerations go in for it than I do
n't know the life  duration of the excited
states or something like that what
is important for that yes i have thanks for the
question that is a question that comes up gladly
also because brilliant um is of course
not toxic however on the level a lot of
handling with individual atoms
so in every rally spring  there is
probably more beryllium in it than
we will ever use for the
individual atoms f if you have a little idea of the periodic table of the e
ements then
t is so
ted into groups with 1 elect
on two electrons on th
very outside of the  outermost shell and
then in the second group we have
systems with two electrons and if
you now take away one electron then
what you need to ionize it to
hold it with electric fields
then you can once
again have a system effectively a 1 an
individual  electrons that
are buzzing around the outside and such an electron
system can be manipulated very nicely  ren
with lasers that's why it's
helpful to have such an electron system
and
maybe ludwig can briefly say why he
likes the panel particularly well
the panel is just very very light yours
and a very light atom
and that's why you can do that very much  good in
the trap and very good means
that the quantum operation is
particularly fast and that is
just one argument that speaks in favor of beryllium
another argument is that it has
a comparatively simple atomic
structure so it has premium and magnesium
have such a nice hierarchy
of states that the decay
always takes place in the same
direction where the excitation
took place this is no longer the case with
the heavier elements at some point
and then it becomes
more complex, for example with
calcium these other atoms then have
other advantages  the heavier the atoms
become, the more the
waves travel  lengths that you need for the optical
control in the red so if with
brilli around the wavelength 313 is in the uv
and 33 10 nanometers and with magnesium
280 nanometers its seat with calcium is
already 397 nanometers and so it
moves further and further into the red and that if
you can  if you want to scale the quantum computer
, you also have to bring the light
for the detection and cooperation of the
lapwing to the man at some point or
bring actions and you can build
such waveguides into the chip
and make integrated photonics and that
doesn’t work particularly well for the uv
, you could probably do that
make it a 20-year research program
to develop this technology
so maybe if you
want to do integrated photonics like this what
we are
also pursuing now in the context of larger projects together with
partners that you then use calcium for example
maybe you can say something else
which atoms are now specific for clocks
are suitable exactly so with the
clocks there you have similar criteria the
level structure is the
main criterion here we need the transition to
the excited state as insensitive as possible to
external disturbances i.e. as insensitive as possible to
magnetic fields electric fields
and relatively
long-lived if we
bring atoms into the excited state
then  they normally fall
back after a certain time and
there is an optimum yes we would
like it to be a few hundred
seconds that would be ideally adapted to the
current technology
and according to these criteria we
will select the clock atoms and he will
give each  amount that you can
also use calcium strontium
terbium and in my working group
we work with aluminum, which is also a
relatively ideal system
if you have any further questions,
we are always happy to help.
we also have an
easteregg hidden in the  cool  or guide
i don't know if anyone
noticed it
i just have my question about the
experiments in relation to black
matter i understood correctly that
it is assumed that there is also a
matter in switzerland that individual particles
vibrate and the vibration
then have an interaction  do with it
if you like i can say a little bit
about that so
there are theoretically
different models of what dark
matter could actually be and one of
the simpler models is that
kalla falls like maybe temperature
also as a gall field
can be interpreted and in particle
physics there is always such that the
interaction is mediated via particles
so to speak yes in optics the photons are
that you already know that
and that is exactly how there would also be
interactions particles the dark
beard dark matter from which the
field then exists and they have a
certain mass, yes, and gradually emerged  n
we know that mass is equal to energy
and that means that depending on the mass
, these particles oscillate with
a certain oscillation frequency
that corresponds exactly to this associated
energy and this type of oscillation
if it is slow enough, yes, if
the if the particles are as light as possible
then this frequency is correspondingly low, by the way,
then we could see it
as an oscillation on the frequencies
ratio of two optical
clocks actually that is the idea
behind it there is another model where
you could also detect heavier dark matter
where the oscillation
frequency for the direction much too
it would quickly be where the
where the but the dark matter
folded itself up in the universe
and we simply due to
gravitational interaction there are simply
clumps of dark matter and we on
our spaceship earth fly
through such a clump then
we would get out of one  area with lower
density  darker matter area
greater densities of dark matter fly
and if there is then an
interaction with normal matter
then the
energy levels would shift again and
we would see that as a drift
essentially going through this boundary layer
then
the clock frequencies would also shift again  offset against each
other and we could
detect that
i have a question about the
computing power so now these are the
microscopic systems that
we have been looking at and now for how
should i normal citizens would be
interesting what can such a
system then calculate as a whole so where is it
you compare to classic
computers and where do you stand there
maybe in five or ten years i know
how long the project has been in place
so
will you be there in the future
exactly so thank you very much for the question that
is an incredibly relevant question
yes i tried them in the rating
in the  conveying
evaluation criteria that the number of cubes is not the only value that is now relevant for evaluating the computing power of such
a device if you have a classic
computer then one way of
measuring the performance of the
system is to use so-called
benchmarks  carry out i.e. how quickly
or in what time are certain
tasks solved in office or how
the performant is a 3d shooter or
other other benchmarks
and there is
not necessarily always one
answer that fits all questions which
you can probably
make clear in general  can and what is worth
keeping in mind is that a
quantum computer can in principle solve all the
tasks that a classic computer can
also solve it can, so to speak, process the
same arithmetic operations and
algorithms, but it is
not necessarily better than a
classic computer
when I use a quantum computer  with
1000k  ibiz then
video conferences excel word
is a classic computer
vastly superior to the standard tasks that we have in it so
you have to
imagine a quantum computer like such a co-processor
there were some in the 90s with the first
pcs that you
could plug in an additional processor when it got
mathematically demanding,
which then solves certain
optimization tasks, i.e. whether tasks
that a quantum
computer cannot solve in principle in a classic computer
because it will simply take the
age of the universe or the length of its lifespan
of the universe would take to process such
tasks we can process with the
quantum computer
classic example which is always
brought up if you 128 elementary
magnets let's take electrons
sift 128 electrons into a
bowl which each electron is a
small magnet of the most open base
cupid  yes de  nn can have a spin
alignment and now you want to
calculate how these 128 electrons
behave that that does
n’t sound so difficult at first it’s a
manageable system but if you take it with you
with all the quantum degrees of freedom
and want to calculate reality
what’s happening then you
ask  that they
need resources in the range of
classic bits i.e. zeros and ones
from 10 to the power of 80 to about and that is
about as many bits as there are protons
in the universe that means that is
austria that even for small systems that
behave fully quantum mechanically
classic computers quickly run out of
air and with a
quantum computer would need says for these
128 electrons
128 cubes to map what
now seems not so far away
from where we are
at the end is really relevant the
product of, so to speak, computing accuracy
cupid  number and connectivity also like
the all mitei  being able to talk to each other and
we think that was in the
foreseeable future
when we now want to build this machine,
we can set
a big exclamation mark that will come in areas
that are really no longer
accessible in the traditional way and where you can start
first, for example  quantum mechanical
were able to do quantum mechanical simulations
of chemistry and the like that are
really useful i don't know if
that roughly answered the question
i think the example of what happened with
the electrons is also a
very good
one because then you can imagine
that we are now
would like to be able to do chemistry calculations where it is
really about calculating and determining the properties of accounts of mechanical matter
when it comes
to developing new drugs because
correlations between electrons etc. must also be
taken along and precisely for such
tasks because we can map
them perfectly  on  the quantum computer because it works
with exactly these same
correlations can create a significant
gain. an
example that is always popular
is the haberbosch process for
ammonia synthesis because what basically
allowed it to increase the
human population in the last century from
two billion to what we have today  have
to increase and this haberbosch
process ultimately for fertilizer
production is a process which is a
catalysis process at very high
temperatures and pressures and there are
people who, for example, are seriously
working on quantum chemistry to make chemical
calculations for this catalysis reaction
in order to achieve an increase in the efficiency of
this process  or
to find other processes and of course that
has enormous potential when
you consider the large-scale technical
significance of this process
for mankind and for our co2 balance
i still have a question about these
fiber stretches that you mention  nt
they actually went all over europe
and where these measurements are made, i.e. frequency
shifts, you can
maybe know what to say about the
infrastructure, what it is
necessary for it or how it works,
I’m happy to tell you that, I don’t
think it’s worth mentioning that the glass fibers
are used  are completely normal telekom on the
internet fiber optics that we offer from
the relevant providers and that we
have to provide with special sound, so
the normal it infrastructure doesn't work there
because we have to stabilize the length of the fiber
optics because you
can imagine fiber optics like that you have there
the temperature then changes
slightly remembers the length and it would lead directly to
a frequency shift which
such measurements would of course
detect and then destroy the whole mess and
that's why we need to
stabilize the length and to do that
we need the one with the light in one direction
go and then directly the same
r  direction back and
the normal it infrastructure doesn't allow that and
that's why we have to
install amplifiers special amplifiers the beers work
bidirectionally in both directions
along the route but
for example for the route between
the ptb and strasbourg of 750 kilometers
so there are two amplifiers in between
so it's manageable actually that
's also technology that we
developed ourselves but the drivers have
to rent it
yes if you have any further questions
always
has someone found the easter egg
max tell ludwig
yes the easter egg is quite
good too a
very good internal joke  it happened to
us that i just stood there on
the laboratory tour and i said about
three ions and of course you could see on the
screen relatively well that they
are actually here and that was
n't so easy to see from my point of view
and yes you have to be
able to count that for about two years
banking physicist and I did that
successfully
[music]
good good
[applause]
thank you very much